okay so the last of us is probably my
favorite game of all time I think it's
something that transcends the medium and
it stands toe-to-toe with the best
movies and TV shows it's easy to see why
HBO have developed it into one as well
and throughout this video I'm going to
be discussing why the game's ending is
something that stuck with me since it
first released all the way back in 2013.
it's a game I've completed multiple
times and every time there's a remaster
a remake it's something I pick up day
one just so I can go back to it though
overall the game plays pretty
straightforward what really elevates the
last of us is its character development
and story over the show the third person
survival horror games had become a
staple of the industry after the release
of Resident Evil 4 and though The Last
of Us doesn't really break the mold when
it comes to that the characters go above
and beyond to elevate the entire
experience the ending is no different
and what really pushes it is the fact
that very few words are spoken between
the characters but you can instantly see
what's going on beneath the surface
performance capturing video games is
some yet came all long way over the last
couple of decades and we've pretty much
watched games of all from 2D Sprites to
living breathing people who can betray
their deepest thoughts and their
expressions and also their body language
The Last of Us capitalizes on this
massively and naughty dog arguably
helped to Pioneer The Cinematic
experience that's now a standard in
video games games have always been
criticized for their storytelling but
here was a studio that put that Above
All Else and the game excels because of
it whenever I talk about the ending of
The Last of Us I've always referred to
it as being the Godfather of gaming and
what I mean by that is that it's very
similar to the ending of another of my
favorites The Godfather and with that we
see Michael Corleone descending you
depths and he has his sister's husband
Kell for betraying the family his
girlfriend K goes to him and after
Michael's sister barges in and reveals
the truth Michael lies about it in order
to not destroy the image K has of him
however from the final shot you very
much get the idea that she knows the
truth but that she's willing to accept a
lie because the reality is too horrify
dying we watch as the door closes on her
and its summing it still gives me
goosebumps today due to the symbolism it
carries now the ending of The Last of Us
is in the same vein with Joe lying to
Ellie and we see she very much has to
force herself to believe it because the
Alternatives too devastating to accept
we're very much left wondering if the
person we've followed throughout the
entire story is actually the good guy
well led to believe they are and it
leaves us questioning the final few
moments over and over we've spent hours
and hours being Joel and putting
ourselves in his shoes we've grown a
bond with the guy and seeing him lie
here is completely understandable even
if we don't totally condone it really
speaks to how complex the game is as a
whole and the entire thing operates in
Shades of Gray now in order to talk
about this scene and all that it means
we had to talk about the steps that got
us to this point now this all happens
because of the opening of the game which
completely defines Joel's life in it we
watched Joel and his daughter Sarah on
the night of the cordyceps outbreak
after a rather laid-back introductory
scene you drowning at the deep end and
from the perspective of Sarah he watches
the world descents into chaos no one
knows what's going on and in this Panic
the car they're in with Joel's brother
Tommy is forced off the road Sarah's
unable to walk properly and Joel has to
carry her through the streets as the
infected start to swarm the area they
come across a lone soldier and whilst
this would normally be a sign of safety
in any other situation like this The
Last of Us twist the scenario ordered to
kill a pair the soldier mercilessly
fires on them and he hits Sarah she dies
in Joel's arms in a moment that will
completely rip your heart out of your
chest and it's arguably the most
impactful game opening of all time now
from here we get a 20-year time Jump and
pick it with Joe living in a federal
Outpost working is a Smuggler with his
girlfriend Tess we very much get the
idea throughout the game a chills had to
do horrendous things to survive this
drove a wedge between him and his
brother and it seems like he's a
complete shell of the person that he
used to be Joel's entire Outlook is
based around surviving and he doesn't
care who he has to kill as steal from in
order to do it whether there is a symbol
that ties him back to his own life and
that's the watch that Sarah gave him on
the night she died though it's busted up
and broken he still wears it because
it's the singular memory of his daughter
that remains the cracks in it very much
represent his own psyche in how beneath
the surface he still Longs for a
relationship like the one he had with
his daughter now this very much becomes
the case in Ellie revealed to be immune
to the cordyceps infection she
represents the Hub that Humanity can
find a cure and return to the old life
that everyone likely Longs for Joel and
Tess are tasks with escorting her across
the country to a firefly Outpost we
watch his Joel's slowly lowers his walls
in order to let her in Ellie represents
the daughter that he lost and the chance
to return back to a normal life like
what he had with Sarah there's so many
subtle moments in the game and I love
the point where Joel longingly stares at
his watch almost as if to remind himself
of that life there's also the fact that
he called Sarah baby girl which is
something he later refers to Elias
[Music]
um
after test is killed we see Joe refusing
to talk about it or acknowledge it
because to him it's something else he
won't have to face up to if he pushes it
to the back of his mind however he very
clearly becomes attached to Ellie and he
even refuses to Palm her off to his
brother Tommy at this Outpost we get a
very important scene and which Tommy
says that he returned back to their home
in Texas the night that the outbreak
happened they had to make a run for it
and didn't get the chance to grab any
personal belongings Joel hasn't returned
because of how painful it is to go back
there unless it's remained pretty much
exactly how they left it unless
someone's been through and spammed the
triangle button on every square inch of
the place guilty anyway Tommy found a
photograph of Joel and Sarah but he
refuses to really acknowledge it and
immediately hands it back well then come
the end of the game we learn that Ellie
grab this on the way out and that she
carried it with her ever since she gave
it a Joel and he longingly looks at it
before saying
laughs
no matter how hard you try
I guess you can't escape your past
thank you
now this is clearly a major change in
him rather than refusing to even
acknowledge it he puts it in his pocket
and finally lets that part of his life
back in this moment is very important
for both Joel and Ellie as it's also the
last major conversation that they had
before their quote unquote saved by the
fireflies the pair make their way
underground and after almost drowning
they're taken to the hospital where the
fireflies have made their Camp Jill
wakes up to discover their preparing Ali
for surgery and this is so they can
remove the mutated strain from her which
will finally give us hope for a cure
there's just one thing though Ellie will
die during the procedure and in order to
save Humanity they have to kill her
first she all doesn't get the chance to
say goodbye and instead he's escorted
Away by an armed God now at this point
he pulls a fast one and kills the
soldier before brutally interrogating
him so that he can go and save her
although this is damning Humanity we
completely understand Joel In This
Moment like him we become attached to
Ali throughout the story and spending a
good 10 hours is protecting her the last
thing that we want to see is the
character die in addition to this we've
seen the ugly side of humanity
throughout and obviously question
whether we're even worth saving if the
cost's gonna be one of the only
genuinely good characters that we've met
on the road it's said that children are
our future and I think it's smart to
have the game center around middle-aged
and elderly characters because it shows
how humanity is Sarah Sam and Ellie are
the only child characters in the game
and to have all three die could
completely kill the Outlook that there's
a bright feature ahead of us now even if
Liars were given a dialogue tree during
this moment where we could decide what
to do I still think that the majority of
people would still choose to save Ellie
now the final part of the game follows
him as we move through the hospital
murdering the fireflies and what
probably the last Brain surgeons on the
planet but you understand all of this
because you've been with Ellie and will
do anything to stop her from being
killed you succeed as well and manage to
make it out of the hospital killing more
lean on the way out she very much
represents the opposite side of the
cointgel and do the backstory that we
get filled in you also know that she
greatly cared about Ellie as well she
was entrusted to her by her mother but
Marlene's willing to make the tough
choice for the greater good the needs of
the many outweigh the needs of the
future hair and the pair very much
represented dichotomy over what to do
knowing that they won't stop coming for
Ellie he kills her and it shows just how
low he's willing to go in order to
protect his surrogate daughter now it's
very important to bear in mind that
almost every time we see Marlene she's
wounded and carrying over this is very
much the case in her final scene and she
paints out a sympathetic figure as she
lies on the ground begging for her life
but gel can't have Ellie with a Target
on her back and thus he does what he has
to do in order to make sure Ellie safe
now this entire flashback is told to us
with a backdrop of Ali waking up in the
back of the car still in her hospital
gown Joel peddles her a story about how
there's lots of immune people out there
and how the fireflies have stopped
looking for a cure the story doesn't
really make sense as especially Judah
hairstyle being in her gown but at least
two devastated to question it and she
turns around defeated she then said it's
all been for nothing and this is a
moment that really stands out to me if
we cut back at the giraffe scene Ellie
ends up storming off because Joel offers
her a chance to return back to Tommy's
she says that it can't be for nothing
and that they have to power ahead now
when you think about it the entire cure
storyline that you've spent the last
however many hours pushing through has
been completely pointless and he'd have
been better off just staying at Tommy's
at the midpoint in the game well that
that's never really crossed my mind
until this video because I've been so
wrapped up in the characters even with
the ending I still feel like it's a
triumphant one because you saved Ali and
Joel finally took a step back towards
Humanity rather than being a closed and
cut off person now they could easily end
the game there and I don't think that
many people would have been mad if that
had been the case we just had a major
action scene stopped Ellie from being
hunted and were riding off into the
sunset but the last of us adds an apple
bug that makes its ending something that
will stick with everyone long after they
put the controller down we don't know
how big of a Time Gym there's been in
between the car ride and where we end up
but clearly some time has passed
juxtapositing the Dynamics that we've
had throughout we're now playing as
Ellie and see that gels the far more
talkative one Ali is another reserved
one and it's a complete switcher from
everything that we've had before now
eventually she stops him and brings up
the day that she got bitten and how her
friend Riley wasn't lucky enough to make
it this is Samy that's later explored in
the Left Behind DLC and it's clear that
she suffers from survivor's guilt Joel
mirrors this as well and he says that he
struggled a long time with surviving
this is clearly commenting on how he
died instead of Sarah and he even
touches the watch for a split second to
signify the guilt he feels however he
says you find something worth fighting
for and Ellie very much represents this
had she died then we know that Joel
would have been robbed of his purpose
and that he'd be surviving with nothing
to survive for on top of this she's
clearly been thinking about the fateful
day a lot she asks Joe flat out whether
everything he said is true I swear to me
swear to me that everything that you've
said about the fireflies is true
[Music]
I swear
[Music]
okay now Joe looks hit dead in the eyes
and swears that it was all true now I'm
sure that a lot of you growing up would
tell by your parents to tell them the
truth and they'd often make you look
them directly in the eyes and do it to
see if you were being genuine or not eye
contact is normally seen as being a sign
of honesty however as humans get older
we of course become aware of this and
adapted into our lives it's actually
been said by psychologist that if
someone does this then they're more
likely to be lying because it's very
practiced and we know that it's meant to
convey honesty so we purposely do it now
as we know giola's lying here and thus
him doing this also lets you know how
manipulative he is All That Remains is
Ellie's reaction and to me it conveys so
much now I absolutely love the way this
plays out and as her eyes glance about
we can read doubt suspicion and also
confusion you clearly build up in her
head that he's lying but he's
potentially willing to lie on top of the
lie because he doesn't want to change
the situation between them Ali knows
that if he's lying then he was willing
to murder people just to save her life
and she's clearly very conflicted
because of this now she has a couple of
choices here either she can say he's
lying and this will divide them further
or she can accept their lies and live in
a world where she won't have to deal
with the survivor's guilt or truth that
someone murdered people just to save her
skin it's a tough thing to deal with and
she simply utters the word okay it's not
really an acceptance or denial of
anything and instead she's just taking
everything at face value because the
truth of it's far more horrifying
although I'm spotting off things that
are basically my opinion here it's
completely possible to take your own
interpretation of Ali's thoughts at this
point the game really wants the player
to make up their own mind and everyone
will have their own reading on this
moment personally I do see Alias being
someone who knows the truth because of
the way that Joel acts but she's willing
to bury it because she simply doesn't
want to accept the reality she always
being someone who's done horrendous
things to survive and now we see Ali be
willing to accept a lie in order to do
the same thing so much is given to us in
this moment and that's why the Game
Stands the test of time naughty dog can
release a remake of the game that's
completely the same as the original
because they don't need to change
anything the story is what carries this
and the final scene that haunts the
player is a reason that we keep going
back to it it's why I think the game
showing that we're gonna be talking
about for a long time and now that the
show will be something that people
constantly go back to in order to
re-examine this final scene though I
really enjoy part 2 they could have
easily ended everything at this point
and it's why the ending is perfect now
I'd love to hear your thoughts on it so
I'm turning it over to you comment below
and let me know your thoughts on the
ending how you interpreted it and what
you think of the game we are in a
competition right now and giving away
Dawn of the Dead and Black Adam to three
subscribers on the 15th of January and
all you have to do to begin with a
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the video if you pick the
comments at random end of the month and
the winners of the last one are on
screen right now so that's you then
message me on Twitter at heavy spoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out one of our
breakdowns on screen right now which has
been picked out perfectly for you the
algorithm's done it there's no way
you'll like so definitely go head over
there right after this by the way thanks
for sending you the video I've been poor
I'll see you next time take care peace
[Music]